hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well it is famous
discussion of the three types the three
main sorts of friendships in nicob
McCann ethics book eight one of it okay
try that one more time
in the course of his famous discussion
of the three main types of fractions
where there's some sort of reciprocity
of affection between the people on some
sort of basis Aristotle talks about
friendship in terms of virtue or in
other places also in terms of the good
and she takes this as being really the
primary type of friendship but it's in a
certain way although it provides us a
model for what friendship ought to look
like
and we see it represented quite a lot in
imaginative literature at the same time
it's not very common as we're gonna talk
about and we'll talk about the reasons
for that so it's an interesting point
here that the the most expansive the the
friendship that actually fits the name
friendship the best is in many respects
the least often found so he tells us a
lot of things about it I did a video
comparing the three types of friendship
here I want to concentrate specifically
on the friendships in terms of virtue
because Aristotle considers them to be
so important both for the virtuous
person and also in providing us with a
paradigm for understanding what
friendship really is at its core so like
I said it is the fullest or the most
complete type of friendship
Aristotle sets out a number of criteria
for what friendship ought to encompass
and it's not the case for friendships of
pleasure or friendships of utility that
all of those components of friendship
will necessarily be there or be
developed to the same extent in a
friendship that is based on virtue on
moral excellence there is a greater
possibility for enjoying the full scope
of friendship this is part of what makes
it the least
it's not something that by its very
nature you could have with just about
anyone yeah as a matter of fact from an
Aristotelian perspective it's a
fundamental mistake to think that you're
going to have the capacity to have a
friendship like this with anybody that
you encounter they have to have engaged
in quite a bit of moral development on
their own part so what is characteristic
of this it is it is a reciprocal
friendship and we're here there's
involved what Aristotle calls on teeth
and they sign that means loving in
return on T meaning in return and than
today's thing is the verb that
corresponds to feeling up the the word
for friendship or relationship so both
partners feel a sense of affection a
sense of friendship a sense of even we
could say love towards the other and
what is it based upon it's not based
just upon the fact that they are useful
to each other although good people are
indeed useful to each other as we will
see it's not just based on the fact that
they enjoy each other's company or the
pleasure that they can give to each
other although again as we'll see a
friendship a virtue also encompasses
that dimension this is really a
friendship in the fullest extent because
it's based on the character on the who
that person is at their core of the
other person and both of them are doing
this that's why sometimes we can have
experiences where we thought we were
experiencing this sort of fundamental
intimacy getting to know somebody in in
their core being attracted to that the
lighting in it then also doing the same
with us and then you know the bottom
drops out and we find out that that's
not the case and that's part of why
although Aristotle doesn't discuss this
inside that's part of why we feel that
you know gut-wrenching betrayal in those
sorts of cases where as a business
relationship breaking up should not
bother us to that extent
so the character of the other and what
is found in the character of the other
in order to have this kind of friendship
it's not badness it's instead moral
virtue so you know you can really only
have this kind of friendship in any sort
of reliable lasting way if the other
person actually has some degree of
virtue and we'll talk in a minute about
why perhaps this this this is not
entirely possible for people who are
self-control another thing is that
person is concerned with the noble and
insofar as they are right oriented
insofar as they are virtuous they are
indeed one example of the noble so one
way to to love the the noble the
beautiful the fine it is to love it in
another person and that's part of what
makes this 10 friendship so wonderful if
you have that that reciprocal loving in
return not only do you love the
beautiful but the beautiful or the fine
of the noble loves you back if indeed
you are worthy of that sort of love in
this in this case there aren't of course
you know what Arizona calls unequal
friendships in which perhaps we are
friends with somebody who is clearly
virtuous but we are not virtuous and
they love us back but they don't love us
back for our virtue because we don't
have it so these people are like it says
they resemble each other there's a horny
Lea a resemblance a similarity in virtue
they see things the same way their moral
compasses are we could so we could say
so to speak aligned in the same
directions oftentimes these people will
see each other doing the right thing and
will congratulate each other on it but
want you to go into a lot of explanation
about it because both of them already
understand why doing acts instead of
doing why is in fact the right thing and
they they delight in each other's
company for that reason there's an
intimacy that that's possible there they
both as Aircel says wish the other
person good
which is a component of friendship but
why do they wish the other person good
for the sake of that person because they
actually know who that person is and
they wish them good other types of goods
on account of their goodness so two kegs
of good here perhaps right but you can
also wish that the person continues in
their goodness because that also is a
good thing to be virtuous is not merely
to be good for other people it's to be
good for oneself it's to be in a good
state of personality or character so
there's also several other things about
this this type of friendship that are
very important as well he says that it
requires both time with chronal strength
and familiarity so in an ATM literally
you know being together with each other
we that sometimes this is translated as
intimacy unless you spend an adequate
time with the other person and you are
actually observing what is going on with
them you cannot determine whether they
are just merely acting virtuously that
is acting in accordance with virtue or
whether that's really part of who they
are so you know if you think about
important virtues somebody may be acting
courageous not because he really is
courageous but because he needs to
appear so in order to impress somebody
right somebody may be just but there are
only just because they like to avoid
punishment and you know over time people
will quite walk and reveal their
motivations for why it is that they're
doing things for the priorities that
they they set for the choices that they
make for the commitments that they
follow through it or fail to follow
through on they will let you know what
that is not only by the structure of
their actions and the patterns of them
but by what they say over time the
virtuous
person is going to overtime torque in a
different way than they merely
self-controlled person let alone the
person who is you know motivated by
saying just extrinsic you know reward
and Punishment whose only good because
know you know somebody might be watching
there's something like that
so friendship of that sort requires
quite a bit of time and quite a bit of
paying attention this is part of why it
is not possible to have a lot of friends
like this Aristotle says you know if you
think about the demands of the amount of
time that's required is you're spending
it with this person you can't be
spending it with that person over there
and you could not possibly have a
hundred people that you would devote
this sort of attention to you would have
to end up distributing it so in some way
now of course we might be able to come
up with some computer-aided algorithm
for doing that sort of thing but insul
person this is the personal touch it
really wouldn't be that kind of
friendship you know getting a lot of
badges that tell you that you're
virtuous isn't the same thing as being
virtuous this kind of friendship you
know corresponding to the fact that it
requires some time it also stands the
test of time better than any of the
other kinds of friendship it is the most
lasting one and why is that it's not
liable to break to the two breakups and
why is it not liable to breakups well
because the virtuous person is not going
to be oriented in the same way towards
the typical causes of breakups of
friendship the way that other people
having other kinds of friendship will so
the virtuous person once they're
actually friends with a person who is
also virtuous they're going to want to
hold onto them as a matter of fact
Aristotle even says friends of this sort
attempt to rival each other they try to
do each other more good than the other
person does so you know what would be
examples of this in terms of virtue
justice you know you can reach a certain
sort of limit point with that well what
about generosity the really virtuous
friend is going to be very generous with
their other friend not just because the
other friend is going to be generous
with them in return but because they
want to outdo their friend in the
possession and exercise of the good not
to deprive their friend of the good but
to action increase what's going on
within the relationship and we could say
the same for all sorts of other virtues
as well good humor is probably very
important in their honesty about oneself
right you know what else do you the
other social virtue you know these
people really are virtuous they're
probably not going to have to exercise
the virtue associated with saying no no
let's not do that but but if we imagine
people who are not entirely virtuous but
on the way there perhaps that will be
important one thing that I also do need
to say is people who are self-control
democratic can have something like this
with each other but not fully of it
because what's being admired and the
other person is not the possession of
virtue but we might say being on the way
to virtue being rightly oriented
recognizing that one wants to be
virtuous but is not yet and there are
many people who I think are friends of
that sort and that goes along just fine
so long as they stay on top of that
inner conflict between right principle
the virtue that they're aiming after and
their desires which are not yet brought
into line with with right reason so
they're not entirely again possession of
this kind of friendship but they're on
their way towards that having a virtuous
friend can often be a very great help in
them so this is the the friendship par
excellence for Aristotle like I said it
doesn't happen very often and when it
does happen though the the
compensation for that is that it sticks
around perhaps for the entire lifetime
of the friends